[Music]
pretty little liars man off pilot has
been announced the perfectionist which I
asked you about yep so many of our NATO
is here here it is I think early next
year we start filming okay which will be
really fun how long have you had to keep
this a secret for a year I'm a new way
year ago yeah I'm a good singer fever
come on on that show for seven years I
know what to do but yeah seriously it's
it's really exciting and I love that
it's new but at the same time it feels
like home well it's you and me people we
love it
have you talked to the other girls about
making appearances if it were to get
picked up to series yeah I mean I'm sure
that they will I mean we have to keep
the pol family alive obviously and
Emison of course that's she knows where
I'm going with it no you do and also
Marlene wants to as well like Marlene is
a genius and she knows how to
incorporate all of that so it's gonna be
really fun you know where it picks up
after the Pretty Little Liars series
finale I don't want to get in trouble
but I think it's like a year or two che
also has a new show coming out called
the heiress's also with Marlene not so I
think that's it yeah I mean Marlene just
really likes to keep it in the family
literally like she's she's such an
amazing person she's got such a big
heart and we really love her so much
so the fact that we can all stick
together somehow really means a lot to
us I know that fans were worried that
now that she has her own series and you
have this series it's gonna be hard to
get Emison reunited but I think it helps
because they're both Murli shows 100%
you know where I don't think that'll be
a problem at all and I think the fans
will really appreciate it so that's what
we really care about anyway what part of
Ally are you most excited to continue on
story-wise I mean honestly I'm so glad
that we're kind of picking up where we
left off I think we we left it in such a
good place and I'm excited to be a mom
hell yeah yeah which is so cool so it's
just a fun different experience and I'm
glad that I get to continue the
character she's amazing and I think
honestly you'll see a little bit more of
a feisty side from her now
she's in another element that she's not
used to aside from the new show the
a-team will dance to I can't help myself
on Mondays Dancing with the Stars here's
why
oh my guilty pleasure is baking that's I
mean you have like a whole tire blog
dedicated to it without sugar
it's a bake-off competitions pretty much
our baking with the Stars
so it comes natural yeah are you
surprised at all by how well received
you're being by the judges they seem to
just only love you
Len is saying nice things yeah which I
love now I'm so excited and honestly I'm
having the time of my life it's been so
fun
[Music]
you
[Music]